messieurs bonsoir dans moins d'une
demi-heure nous irons tous ensemble
prendre le chemin de bastia pour le
match aller de la finale de la coupe de
l'uefa bastia eindhoven il a plu des
cordes aujourd'hui en corse
à tel point qu'on a eu peur jusqu'à la
dernière minute que le match ne se joue
pas mais apparemment ça marche
eh bien oui patrick danemark mais ça
marchait difficilement car vous pouvez
constater que le terrain est vraiment
appel jouable l'arbitré monsieur
maksimovic le porte- heureusement est
venu tout à l'heure sur la pelouse alors
qu'il ne pleuvait pas et il a jugé lui
que le terrain était jouable donc le
match a commenté espérant qu'il pourra
se dérouler dans des conditions
régulières qui n'est pas évident lorsque
l'on voit les images que nous donne
actuellement dix rebelles
il pleut à nouveau très porte sur bastia
le match fera très certainement assez
pénible pour l'équipe qui devra faire le
jeu en l'occurrence le parking clos
bedouel de bastia
puisque vous le savez ce soir c'est le
match aller le match retour ayant lieu
dans 14 jours à une aubaine aubin
espérons que tout se passera bien et que
la pluie voudra bien arrêtées espérons
thierry nous vous recommandons dans 25
minutes avec bernard faire pour le
commentaire de ce match bastia and noble
en attendant le deuxième gros titres de
l'actualité c'est la hausse des tarifs
publics dès lundi c'est à dire dès le
1er mai ces prix seront sérieusement
relever comme je vous l'avais laissé
entendre hier ou si bien la sncf copé
dpa le dfco à gdf aussi bien aussi que
pour le tabac et le charbon
et puis à partir du 1er juillet le métro
et le bus davantage de détails avec jean
paul annick c'est aux ptt que revient la
palme des hausses 20% en moyenne le
courrier en vitesse normale devra dès la
semaine prochaine
être affranchis à 1 franc 20 quant au
courrier non urgents il passera de 80
centimes à un franc
côté téléphone la taxe unitaire passera
de 42 à 47 centimes et le jeton de
taxiphone coûtera probablement 50
centimes la semaine prochaine également
à la sncf les tarifs voyageurs vont
augmenter de 15% ce qui va porter le
prix du kilomètre en seconde classe à
près de 21 centimes le parcours
paris-lyon outre a ainsi 56 francs au
lieu de 48 francs les tarifs
marchandises déjà majoré de six et demi
pour cent en février vont subir une
nouvelle hausse de 10%
quant aux prix des trains de banlieue
ils remonteront aussi mais le montant de
la hausse sera fixée ultérieurement avec
la ratp pour le métro parisien
l'augmentation interviendra le 1er
juillet mais d'ores et déjà on sait que
le carnet de seconde classe passera de
11 francs à 12,150 le nouveau prix de la
carte orange sera déterminée d'ici
quelques jours
en liaison avec les métros de marseille
et de lyon
hausse aussi dans l'électricité et le
gaz 10% en moyenne dès le mois de mai et
le comité national des prix qui se
réunit demain à envisager une réforme
des quittances est peut-être la
suppression de certaines tranches
horaires
le charbon lui a augmenté tout de suite
de 8,7 pour cent
enfin les cigarettes vont coûter 15 %
plus cher avec votre paquet de gauloises
ce ne sont plus deux francs qui
partiront en fumée mais de francs 30
et pour mémoire on savait déjà que les
carburants allaient augmenter au 1er
juin
l'essence ordinaire et le super de 16
centimes le gazole de 10 centimes et le
fioul domestique de 5 à 6 centimes
j'ajoute que le smic sera augmentée deux
jours plus tard c'est à dire le 3 mai
d'environ 4% ce qui devrait permettre
aux salariés à revenus modestes de
supporter plus facilement les indices
élevés que l'on attend pour les mois à
venir car la note est lourde
'l'indice de mars qui sera publié demain
devrait être de l'ordre de 0,9 pour ça
raymond barre à la sortie du conseil des
ministres ce matin s'est expliqué sur
ses hausses des tarifs publics
si nous ne procédons pas aux hausses qui
vont intervenir
il y aura pour les entreprises
nationales une aggravation leur déficit
soient déficit d'exploitation soit
insuffisance de ressources pour
d'importants programmes d'investissement
on peut chercher
évidemment du côté des subventions
budgétaires les subventions budgétaires
sont déjà très élevés et si on les
augmente encore
ces subventions nous arriverons à une
situation budgétaire d'ensemble qui sera
préoccupante
on peut recouvrir également à des
emprunts mais les entreprises nationales
recourent déjà de façon considérable à
l'emprunt à long terme et à des crédits
bancaires à moyen et à court terme et ce
n'est pas une bonne chose d'accroître
l'endettement des entreprises
ce même conseil des ministres a entériné
la nomination de nombreux hauts
fonctionnaires je vous donne quelques
exemples car les postes qu'ils occupent
sont importants michel albert devient
commissaire général au plan
andré shadow jusqu alors préfet de la
région nord pas de calais remplacera
françois ici qu à la tête de la datar la
délégation à l'aménagement du territoire
la police aura un nouveau patron jacques
soulier préfet de seine-et-marne en
place robert pandraud qui occupait ce
poste depuis trois ans et demi et qui
devient directeur général de
l'administration et des affaires
politiques au ministère l'intérieur
enfin pierre richard qui était jusqu
alors conseiller technique à l'elysée
devient directeur général des
collectivités locales reste un petit peu
long mais je crois que ce sont des
postes clés de l'administration
française
la politique pure maintenant avec le
comité central du parti communiste
réunis depuis le début de matinée place
du colonel fabien
au programme le rapport de georges
marchais sur la situation politique et
les tâches à venir du parti mais surtout
la réponse que va faire la direction du
pc à la contestation interne
protestation qui trouve son point le
plus haut dans le troisième article du
philosophe louis althusser dans le monde
nous avons atteint dans le parti le
degré zéro de la théorie marxiste
elle a disparu sur place au siège du pc
noël copains
cette discussion à huis clos qui a
commencé ce matin après le nom rapport
de georges marchais qui se poursuivra
pendant presque toute la journée de
demain
on peut penser qu'elle fait et qu'elle
fera un assez large écho à toutes les
critiques qui ont été formulées ces
jours ci ses critiques on le sait et man
d'intellectuels communiste de
personnalités très différentes comme par
exemple louis althusser qui passe pour
un intégriste ou comme jean epstein qui
au contraire est considéré comme un
libéral mais ces critiques concernent
tout le fonctionnement du parti
communiste auquel il est reproché de ne
pas être assez démocratique
ces critiques que concernées également
certains aspects de la campagne et en
particulier ce que louis althusser
appelé petit guerre le double langage et
la double stratégie alors que peut-il se
passer
on peut penser que la direction du parti
communiste va lâcher un peu de lest en
ce qui concerne la liberté de discussion
ce matin par exemple rené andrieu
rédacteur en chef de l'humanité 10 est
une nouvelle fois qu'il serait possible
d'envisager ultérieurement l'ouverture
d'une tribune de discussion dans la
presse du parti et communistes la
direction acceptera sans doute aussi
quelques critiques sur le style de la
campagne sur quelques points
particuliers de cette campagne mais on
peut penser en revanche qu'elle
maintiendra ce que l'humanité appelé
l'analyse de fond on peut penser aussi
qu elle justifiera la ligne générale
politique du parti
et puis que pour réaliser l'unité du
parti et le relancera les thèmes du 22e
congrès et qu'une fois de plus c'est le
fera porter sur le parti socialiste
la responsabilité de la rupture de la
gauche et de son échec
wintek de monsieur marc chèze sera
publié après demain dans l'humanité
300000 exemplaires supplémentaires
seront vendues après le point du jour
c'est une autre publication communiste
qui disparaît paris hebdo par yendo qui
s'était distingué par des analyses
disons plus critique de la position du
pc une grève aux ptt aujourd'hui 42 % de
grévistes pour le ministère des
possibles parisiens qui ont répondu aux
consignes de grève des syndicats cgt
force ouvrière et cfdt
un espoir devrait week end aux ptt un
député rpr condamné pour diffamation
envers un ministre la chose est rare il
s'agit de monsieur masson qui avait
battu alice saunier séité à metz et puis
trois journaux également condamné pour
diffamation envers un ancien ministre
jacques médecin et parmi ces journaux le
canard enchaîné qui fêtait aujourd'hui
son 3000e numéro il fait être à sa
manière puisqu'il met en cause l'actuel
premier ministre raymond barre donc
soupçonné de posséder six actions au
liechtenstein une valeur de 14 200
francs tout le conseil des ministres
d'aujourd'hui a aussi évoqué la
situation de jade et s'est déclaré prêt
à prendre les dispositions nécessaires
pour assurer la sécurité des coopérants
français là bas un certain nombre de nos
compatriotes ont en effet été molestés
hier au tchad le tchad un pays déchiré
et en prennent incertitudes politiques
pour la première fois sans doute ce sont
des français qui ont été visés hier par
les violentes manifestations organisées
par le frolinat dans le sud du tchad
avec aussi cette confirmation venu de
paris
l'identité des deux coopérants français
tué le 19 avril dernier à salal un poste
militaire aujourd'hui encore aux mains
du frolinat et celle de la reprise des
combats dans tout l'est du pays où le
front national de libération du tchad
semble en position de force
prêt à prendre le contrôle des
principales localités dans la capitale
djamena rien pour l'instant ne semble
bouger mais le frolinat a lancé un mot
d'ordre de grève générale pour jeudi et
vendredi
action psychologique qui visait tout
d'abord le gouvernement du président
malloum et qui se dirigent maintenant
contre les coopérants français civils ou
militaires universités écoles viennent
d'être fermés pour éviter toute
manifestation
le président malloum a demandé au
gouvernement français de tout mettre en
oeuvre pour assurer la sécurité des
coopérants en rappelant qu'un accord de
cessez-le-feu a été signé le 27 mars
dernier sans résultat jusqu'à présent
et robert galley les musettes opération
aujourd'hui déclaré à l'assemblée que
les coopérants militaires français qui
se trouvent au tchad pouvaient être
amenés à participer à des opérations de
logistique
une dernière dépêche que longtemps un
attentat à naples où se dire en israël
deux touristes allemands tués à la suite
de l'explosion d'une charge qui est
élancé dans un autobus
le point maintenant sur ce qui se passe
en italie reviennent bien nouveau dans
la sphère proprement dite de
l'enlèvement d'aldo moro si ce n'est ce
nouvel appel du pape qui a souhaité que
la conclusion de ce drame soit pacifique
et tranquillisants dans l'intérêt même
agresseur a dit le saint père devant dix
mille fidèles
rassemblés au vatican et puis cette
nouvelle journée d'attentes avait débuté
à rome par l'attentât de contre l'ancien
président de l'exécutif de la région du
latium
monsieur mais kelly qui a été blessé aux
jambes par quatre projectiles c'est le
sixième attentat des brigades rouges
depuis l'enlèvement du président de la
démocratie chrétienne prom sur place
victor vraiment en lançant un appel en
italien aux brigades rouges
monsieur van damme le secrétaire général
des nations unies était certainement
rempli de bonnes intentions
et pourtant cet appel qui a été
retransmis par satellite a été très
critiquée en italie
comment voilà monsieur valdan le
secrétaire général des nations unies qui
s'adresse directement aux brigades
rouges qui dit que les terroristes ont
déjà réussi à attirer l'attention du
monde entier qui explique qu'en libérant
aldo moro les brigades rouges recevront
l'adhésion de tous ceux qui luttent pour
la justice sociale ce qui revient dans
une certaine mesure a justifié l'action
idéologique des brigades rouges
pour prendre un exemple le 'corriere
della sert écrit aujourd'hui que paul 6
et valdan on accorder une reconnaissance
politique aux brigades rouges aux
terroristes alors qu'il ne constitue
qu'un petit groupe complètement isolé du
reste de l'opinion publique italienne
moche et diana washington le ministre
israélien des affaires étrangères est
venu dans la capitale américaine pour
essayer de recoller les morceaux entre
les deux pays par les rapports s'étaient
très distendus depuis le voyage de
monsieur begin là bas et pourtant moshe
dayan ne soumettra aucune proposition
nouvelle à washington
une proposition nouvelle pour la paix au
proche orient dans les bagages du
général moshe dayan trois jours
d'entretiens avec monsieur cyrus vans le
secrétaire d'état américain ne suffiront
pas à aplanir les divergences entre
washington et jérusalem
les américains voudraient qu'israël
s'engage à évacuer les territoires
conquis pendant la guerre des six jours
mais la veille de l'arrivée à washington
du général moshe dyan monsieur begin
affirmait que tout accord de paix doit
comprendre le maintien des colonies
juives
jamais les positions américaines et
israéliennes n'ont été si éloignés mais
l'obstacle numéro 1 reste la fourniture
de ces fameux 200 avions de chasse f 15
et f 16 à israël à l'egypte et à
l'arabie séoudite le président carter
soucieux du maintien de l' équilibre des
forces
soucieux aussi de renforcer l'armement
dadié arabes comme l'egypte refuse de
vendre uniquement à israël pour 10me
carter cette vente d'avions doit être
globale
car il en va de la sécurité des états
unis mais les parlementaires du congrès
qui doivent se prononcer cette semaine
sur la fourniture de ces 200 avions de
chasse aux pays du proche orient n'en
sont guère convaincu des ouvriers
français contre un patron soviétique
la situation n'est pas banal ça se passe
à besançon dans la filiale d'une
entreprise soviétique cela va essayer
dans l'horlogerie 75 salariés en tout
dans ce petit atelier 30 français
demandent une augmentation de salaire
les dix ouvriers soviétique ne demande
rien et le patron lui soviétique lui
aussi dit non après cinq jours de grève
les négociations ont repris ce matin
sans succès les ouvriers réclament
toujours 5 % d'augmentation un 13e mois
et les 40 heures pour eux peu importe la
nationalité du patron il faudra bien
négocier pense que ce sont les patrons
vous soient patrons français
le problème nous exactement le même on
s'adresse à un patron
la preuve en est que quand les
revendications deviennent délicates des
français au rebond
à l'origine ce l'avant entreprises
horlogères créé par les soviétiques
devait leur permettre de se familiariser
avec les méthodes de gestion capitaliste
mais aujourd'hui leur faut faire face
aux revendications de la cfdt une
section s'est créé ici il y a un an et
30 des 75 employés de l'usiné poursuivre
la grève mais sans que les dix ouvriers
soviétique y participent
aujourd'hui l'augmentation de 4 %
proposée par la direction est jugée
insuffisante
il faut négocier l'ensemble des
problèmes exigent des syndicats la
cinquième semaine de congés par exemple
pour le patron soviétique les décisions
fortement régressives simple du recteur
pour qui
cinq employés aux biens auriez peut
venir pour discuter de toutes les
questions qui est lui concerne et nous
pourrons toujours de résoudre cette
question à l'amiable à 22h15 tout de
suite après le match de bastia un match
qui aura lieu nous a livré leur tient et
roland ribes et quelle france ce
magazine dont je vous ai déjà parlé qui
sera consacré ce soir aux pyrénées
atlantiques un film d'eric louer ricqlès
et philippe gildas et un film qui
apparemment ne plaît pas à tout le monde
cheville a quelques problèmes curé vous
que lundi dernier nous sommes allés
présenter à pau puisque c'est un film
sur les pyrénées atlantiques et une
somme jamais présenté au personnel local
et à la presse
une démarche pour laquelle jean pierre
elkabbach et moi-même ou non la fois
montrer notre volonté de dialogue et en
temps indiqué que nous n'avions rien à
cacher en plus nous y attend étions
fiers de faire connaître à la fois
l'intérêt et j'allais dire l'affection
que nous portons région puisque
maintenant il s'agit d'une nouvelle
politique d'ouverture la france profonde
tels que le président enrique n 2 elle a
défini alors bon c'est vrai l'accueil a
été mitigé et une grande partie de la
presse locale n'était pas très favorable
aux fines
enfin ce n'est pas anormal puisque
l'ensemble de la presse nationale
il était elle plutôt favoris alors le
lendemain c'est à dire hier le conseil
général des pyrénées atlantiques a émis
le voeu que le sujet ne passe pas aurait
été programmée il passera bon
le conseil général et son président de
ceux du ghost auront s'ils le souhaitent
les droits de réponse
en face une péripétie qui ne doit pas
empêcher les téléspectateurs de voir le
film à 22h20 et de voir les autres
chaque mois les autres films 50 ou sur
d'autres départements vais rester avec
nous le guerriau et regarder ce qui va
suivre ça commence comme une histoire
belge mais c'est presque une catastrophe
nationale
figurez vous qu'on a volé ce matin le
manneken pis à bruxelles dirais que
c'est pas la première fois que l'un
public petit bonhomme excite les
convoitises mais cette fois ci sur la
piste pour antenne 2 l'inspecteur cazals
à bruxelles une fois il y a deux
traditions la première et la deuxième
la première veut qu'un étranger en
visite dans la capitale belge of au
manneken pis un costume de son pays
comme le fait ici
senoble compatriotes de mister picwic
c'est dit pas mieux comme ça la deuxième
tradition veut que périodiquement le
manneken pis disparaissent enlevé par
quelques collectionneurs magna qui part
quelques joyeux plaisantin pour l'heure
la police penche plutôt pour une
troisième hypothèse la fugue amoureuse
le manneken pis seraient partis vers le
nord irrésistiblement attiré par le
chant de la petite sirène de copenhague
avant la météo les numéros du loto qui
viennent de nous parvenir le cincle 24
le 28 le 29 ou le 30 sept
le 45 et le 40 pour le numéro
complémentaire écrit moi d'aller vite on
est obligé voilà les prévisions pour
demain donc de la météo un temps nuageux
avec pluies ou averses ou orages surtout
le pays seul le nord-est bénéficiera de
quelques belles éclaircies et des
températures seront basses pour la
saison
antenne de vous donne trois rendez-vous
ce soir à l'actualité le premier le
temps d'une page de publicité c'est la
rencontre bastia eindhoven forza bastia
et puis le deuxième à 22h15 question de
temps vous l'a dit et puis enfin le
troisième le dernier journal présenté
par gérard holtz orienté vers 23h15 à
vous remercie de votre attention et puis
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée l
écoute de nos programmes
bonsoir à tous à demain
à